souvient la guerre mais ma mémoire me
fait défaut
l'office national du film présente
aujourd'hui sa première expérience
consacrer exclusivement à la réalité
virtuelle dans le cadre des rencontres
internationales du documentaire de
montréal
un de ces documentaires vous envoyer des
images en ce moment s'appelle le
photographe inconnue et il nous amène au
coeur des souvenirs d'un soldat de la
première guerre mondiale très
intéressant mathieu bonsoir cellule
alors je regarde ici je vois que voici
toutes équipées dont on l'avait vu ce
documentaire répète même dire je l' ai
vécu parce que c'est vraiment ce qu'on
dit quand on vit une expérience en
réalité virtuelle on est littéralement
au centre de l'action alors ce film là
s'appelle le photographe inconnue une
oeuvre de loïc city pour lodève donc
première oeuvre entièrement été en
réalité virtuelle pour le nf
on se promène littéralement dans les
souvenirs d'un soldat qui ai vécu la
première guerre mondiale on a une petite
manette et l'on se promène littéralement
dans ce qui ressemble peut-être à sa
tête à ses souvenirs on voit des photos
et donc on se déplace là dedans quelque
chose de très onirique et c'est à noter
que ce cette oeuvre là est la plus
longue des plus longues jamais créé en
réalité virtuelle dans le monde
elle sera d'ailleurs présenté dans le
cadre du festival du film international
du documentaire d'amsterdam à la fin
novembre alors c'est une oeuvre déjà qui
fait parler d'elle donc il ne va après
20min vingtaine de minutes et je vous
écoute et je me rendais ce que c'est
encore du documentaire mais en fait
c'est la grande question à vous savez
tous les grands festivals de films dans
le monde
intègrent de plus en plus qu on appelle
ces nouvelles écritures là dans leur
programmation le tiff tribeca sound and
mind kahn a lancé on est vraiment dans
une tendance mondiale le rdm en sont à
leur quatrième édition de cette web doc
barres obliques oeuvre en réalité
virtuelle on a fait sur le x doc dans
leur cas et donc on pourrait dire que
cette technologie là est un peu
l'équivalent de ce que la télévision
était pour l'information début des
années 50 ans était très balbutiant
savais pas trop quoi faire avec ce
médium là et aujourd'hui c'est un peu ça
on est en train de créer la gué la
l'écriture de ce la grammaire de sites
ce médium le alors c'est très
intéressant de voir que le canada est
vraiment là l'avant plan là dedans
monde donc ça s'est ouvert à tous et de
la cinémathèque jusqu'au 22 novembre
donc si vous voulez ya livre puis vivre
ces expériences là il y aussi des web
documentaires qui sont présentés city le
webdocumentaire là on peut aussi les
regarder en ligne mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que de plus en plus la
forme du journalisme la forme du
documentaire éclate et ses technologies
led contribuent
on est vraiment en train d'assister à la
naissance d'un nouveau genre et on voit
que c'est au canada jazeera qui a
commandé à huy gézira cadets que ce
genre là une oeuvre interactive à une
boîte de montréal alors c'est dire que
la réputation le du québec et du canada
dépasse de beaucoup les frontières dans
ce domaine là merci il est venu nous en
parler de saisir céline